I tried with Sam.
I wanted to save him.
Well, I reckon it's
a lot more complicated than that.
Tell me those things
that you charge me for.
I wanted those things to keep us alive.
I'm looking for my brother
Tommy!
We did those things.
They weren't things.
We murdered people.
Be careful who you put your faith in.
The only people who can betray us.
Otherwise, we trust.
Welcome back everyone
It's Charlie.
This will be my last of us episode
6 Trailer Video.
There's a whole bunch of Easter eggs
and references. We'll break it all down.
If you're brand new to the channel, be
sure to subscribe to get all the episodes.
It's only going to get crazier
from here on out.
We're doing a giveaway
for HBO Max subscriptions.
All you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber
and just post your favorite moment
from the trailer on the video.
Careful for spoilers from episode five
if you haven't seen it yet, but
the title of the episode is Kin,
a reference to Joel
reuniting with his brother Tommy, finally
at a settlement in Jackson, Wyoming.
There's been a bit of a time jump
since the end of episode five.
Obviously sees snow all over the ground,
so it's become winter.
They'll probably address
this during the episode
because Joel told Henry, R.I.P.,
Henry and Sam.
Great episode last week.
Great Henry and Sam Arc.
He told them it was going to take them
a long time to get to Wyoming.
In the game,
it was fall like there was a big time jump
after they leave Henry and Sam's bodies.
But in the game, when they reached Tommy's
settlement, it wasn't quite winter yet.
Like there wasn't snow on the ground.
That didn't happen
to a little bit later in the game.
So they might have combined
a couple of events that happened
later in the story.
I think the showrunner
probably just said that to mark
the passage of time a little bit more,
just to show you how long it's been,
how long it's
taken them to get that much further
across the United States.
But just starting
at the beginning of the trailer,
Joel is talking to Elliot,
a campfire on their way out
because she's sad about not being able
to save Sam, about thinking
that her blood might be able to cure him.
Joel trying to explain to her that it's
probably going to be a little bit
more complicated, that, like,
he can't just bleed on someone else
and use your blood to cure them.
She's not some sort of infected vampire
or something like that.
There are a lot of questions about
what was happening during that scene.
Like, did she actually believe that
holding her hand bleeding to his leg
would actually cure him?
Or was she just doing that
to try and make him feel better?
The way she talks around the campfire.
It makes it sound like she actually did
believe that it would work.
One of the other changes from the game
is that she didn't
leave him a note because he wasn't deaf.
He didn't have the notepad
and was writing notes that way.
The reason
why they include a couple of flashbacks
is just because it kind of traumatizes
Ellie in a much bigger way.
And it's part of this larger
arc about the way she feels,
how she's responsible for the human race
with the idea that she could
potentially create a cure using her body
in the idea that Joel is slowly
coming around on this idea of redemption,
which is a big part of his storyline
with Tommy during the episode,
because a lot of his scenes with Tommy
in the trailer are Tommy being remorseful
about what they've done and seeking
forgiveness, seeking redemption.
And Joel's slowly on that path, too.
He just hasn't quite hit
the point that Tommy has hit.
Then we see Tommy's settlement in.
The whole idea here is that
this is meant to be
a small, independent settlement
that isn't another quarantine zone,
and it's not another group of fireflies
or, like, another really terrible group.
It is a genuine, good group of people
trying to survive on their own
in a small settlement,
even though it seems like
a very well-developed settlement with
a bunch of people, it's relatively small
compared to a normal quarantine zone.
Joel and Ellie arrive on
horseback in the town through the gates.
This is this giant gate, the front of it,
and he sees Tommy working on something
with one of the other people,
and they reunite.
They're all right.
But no, these people know him
as my goddamn brother, Tommy.
Holy shit.
How you doing? My brother got down.
Yeah, I mean, look at you, Maria.
Be nice to her.
She sorta runs things around here, ma'am.
Thanks for that ball. My head off
would have been embarrassing,
considering you're my brother
in law.
We all got to get wrangled up
at some point.
Big video game Easter because we're seeing
Tommy in episode six again.
If you remember Perry on the show
in episode four and Episode
five was played by the actor
who did Tommy in the video games.
The whole reason for him coming to Wyoming
in the first place looking for Tommy
is because
he hadn't heard from him in weeks
and he'd been communicating
with him in the past,
even though they've been estranged
for a little while.
They'd still been communicating The way
he explained their back story to Ellie
is that in 2003,
after the initial fungus outbreak,
they traveled with a group of hunters
like he was part of the Hunters group,
the same group that Kathleen came from
while they were headed to the Boston
Quarantine zone.
And that's
what he's talking to about Tommy,
about killing all these people
because they had to survive
and being remorseful for that.
All the quote unquote,
terrible things that they done.
They're not things.
They're people
We killed a bunch of people.
The way Joel explained it to Ellie,
he only came along to keep an eye
on his brother, Tommy.
He didn't want to kill all those people.
He didn't relish in all that violence.
He was just trying to keep Tommy safe.
His whole reason
for continuing in the apocalypse,
even though it's terrible like he was
talking to Ellie, is because of family.
To keep family safe.
He did all those terrible things
to protect his family.
And that's a big part of his character
arc during the season.
Like he'll continue
to do very controversial things for what
he considers his family. Eventually.
That's going to include
Ellie. He's not quite there yet.
Like he doesn't totally think of her
as his daughter yet.
And that might be part
of the episode, too.
Like them actually
addressing the elephant in the room.
Is she still just a responsibility to him?
How does he feel about her now
after everything they've been through?
While they were traveling to Boston
and doing all these terrible things,
it sounds like Tommy was really, really
against it and wound up meeting Marlene
and she offered him a different path,
like she sold him on the fireflies plan
of saving the world, looking for a cure,
and overthrowing Phaedra
and installing a civilian government.
That is one of the Fireflies
big goals, like they are one of the big
alternate factions to Phaedra.
But also the Hunters are another faction
in the
of a bunch of smaller rogue factions
living outside the quarantine zones.
Most of them are all pretty terrible.
And the idea is that
the fireflies are also doing
very terrible things too, but
they're not quite as terrible as Phaedra,
and they just feel like they can install
a civilian government that will work
a little bit more like society worked
before the fungus outbreak.
Like, yes, life will be bad,
but we can make it slightly less bad.
And as Joel explains, as things continue,
they met Tess.
He developed his relationship
with Test slowly over time.
It sounds like they got to Boston
and then immediately split off
from that group of hunters like Jules.
They left that group
as soon as they could.
Tommy meets Marlene
and joins the fireflies,
and they start doing their thing,
just enacting their slow
plan to get rid of Phaedra.
And it sounds like that took him out West
and he was communicating with him
over that period of time.
But depending on how long you think it's
been since the events of episode
one during episode one,
he said it'd been about three weeks
since he's heard from Tommy,
and the reason
why he stopped hearing from him is because
Tommy left to join this settlement.
He met a woman who we see in the trailer
here.
It seems like
this is going to be his wife.
He fell in love with this woman
and then joined the settlement
that she was part of.
Like she and the rest of the people that
she was with had this small settlement.
So Tommy joined up with them
and they're trying to make it
the best place they can in the apocalypse.
I think it's implied that the Fireflies
were doing really terrible stuff,
too, making Tommy do terrible stuff,
and that's why he left them.
And it's supposed to make Joel's decisions
at the end of the series.
And what happens with Ellie ultimately?
Because the whole idea is that
he's taking her to the fireflies.
A little bit easier for him to make.
Like he has to make a bunch
of controversial choices.
And they use a lot of Kathleen's speech
at the end of episode five,
where she talks about Henry choosing
Sam over the rest of the people.
They're like, Is he more important
than the rest of the human race?
So a lot of that is meant to inform
the choices that Joel has to make.
Like, is Ellie more important
than the rest of the human race
because she could
potentially save the human race?
So there's a lot of those deep
conversations
going on during this episode,
The next couple of episodes,
probably where Ellie starts to reckon
with that, like her greater responsibility
in Joel, thinking about his greater
responsibility to her.
Most of the actual settlement
here is meant to be accurate to the game.
Like all the different buildings
and all the people running around here.
You also notice when they ride into town,
there's a banner that says 23
because it's kind of frozen in time.
In 2003, when the first big fungus
outbreak happened and things went crazy,
Tommy argues with Joel
about the terrible things
that they did
when they were part of the hunters.
Like I said,
Joel hasn't totally come around on it.
Like he still believes
that he did what he had to do.
He hasn't completely reckoned
with all the terrible things yet.
This whole conversation that Ellie has is
just about the people closest to you
being able to betray
you much more easily than strangers
or more likely to betray you.
That's meant to be a reference to Joel,
just because Joel is the person
that she is closest to right now,
I think is just a foreshadow
something that happens
at the end of the season.
No spoilers about that.
We'll talk about that
in a couple more episodes,
but that's meant to flow with the idea
that Joel does whatever he has to do,
quote unquote, like he told her earlier.
And he's talking to Tommy
about four family in the name of family.
So even if he does terrible things,
they want to make you understand
why he's doing them.
So at least you identify with that, even
if you don't agree with what he's doing.
When all the people on the horseback
find them here and see what
they're trying to capture them,
I actually think that it's
just other people from Tommy's settlement.
And that'll be the surprise.
Like, No, no, we're friendly.
We'll take you to the settlement.
This person with the baseball bat
kind of looks like Troy Baker.
He is part of the series,
but he's actually part of the cannibals
group from later in the games.
So they might be combining his group
a little bit sooner
or they might be part of the story
with his group,
and they might just do that
in two different episodes.
I don't want to get too much into
what happens with their group
because in the game it happens much later
and it is like a really big WTF moment
and it seems like most of episode
six will be dedicated
to what's happening around
Tommy's settlement.
This person to a remote cabin
might either be a flashback
or somebody that they encounter
on their way to Tommy's settlement.
This scene of them arriving
at the building here with Ellie shooting
behind them
seems like it's
the university from the game,
which is where they're looking
for the fireflies.
The whole idea is that
Tommy used to be part of the fireflies
and is supposed to give them information
about how to find them.
But when they arrive at the place
that Tommy told them
to go to at this university,
they find it abandoned in a note
that the fireflies left saying
that they retreated to Salt Lake City.
And a lot of that
they'll probably cover in later episodes.
There are nine episodes
total in season one.
I'm not sure how much plot
they're going to cover in episode six,
but the whole idea is that they do not
find the fireflies for a good long while.
If you spot it any other Easter eggs
or references in the trailer footage
that I didn't talk about in the video,
just write them below in the comments.
My full Episode
six video will post next week.
I believe they're going back
to the regular schedule of episodes two.
They only aired episode five early
just because of the Super Bowl.
Episode six will probably be next Sunday,
not this Sunday, but the Sunday after.
And because it is Super Bowl weekend,
there are a bunch of Super Bowl trailers
like there's like five videos already
that I'm trying to work on right now.
Make sure you enable alerts for my channel
so you don't miss any of those.
We have the flash trailer.
There's a bunch of Marvel trailers.
I believe there's going to be Guardians
of the Galaxy 3 trailer, New Ant-Man
and the Wasp Quantumania trailer video.
Probably a couple of surprises too.
I'll probably be doing trailer videos
for like the next four or five days.
I think there's also going to be
some New Mandalorian Season
3 footage, too,
because they're dropping so much
new stuff.
Those will be the next episodes
that I started
doing at the beginning of March
when it premieres another big Pedro Pascal
series,
Pedro Pascal, into the Pascal verse.
Everyone click here for My Fool,
Last of US Episode five Video
and click here to learn about
Christian Bale coming back as Batman.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one.